so we tend to take the news day by day
here we look at each element of what has
taken place we analyze it for its
factual substrate and we contextualise
the news in history or society or
culture or the economy or science or
whatever is warranted by what's taking
place we're sort of at the endpoint here
with Donald Trump we have a president
who simply can't do his job and Donald
Trump is long past the moment where he
should resign the presidency of the
United States because the pandemic
crisis that Donald Trump is dealing with
or better said not dealing with has
proven that he can't lead he can't
handle this and we already suspected
that we many of us on the Left we
already knew that before but it should
really be clear to anyone who's willing
to apply the most minut amount of
critical thinking at this point he has
mishandled it with lies and delays and
ignorant and incompetence from day one
and people are dying and the pandemic is
spreading and to really understand this
you actually have to go back years when
Donald Trump expressed back during the
Republican primary in 2015
vaccine skepticism he's not an
anti-vaxxer but expressed fact-free
unscientific vaccine skepticism that was
a sign that this guy was not playing
with a full deck then he became
president of the United States he
disbanded the pandemic response team why
would anyone do that the medical field
knows that there are you know hundred
year flus there's the idea of thousand
year viruses it's just a matter of time
until we're faced with one trump
disbands the pandemic response team cuts
funding to the CDC so you have a
cluelessly vaccine skeptical guy
disbanding the pandemic response team
and cutting CDC funding nothing's
happened yet
at that point but it's already bad then
this starts to spread out of China Trump
does nothing for a while says it's all
fine it's all gonna go away it starts to
get weird then he makes completely
reckless baseless predictions about we
won't really have cases than we have
them we're not going to have deaths than
we have them there was never any basis
in fact or science in any of those
prediction
On February 29th Trump said the closest
he said the number of people infected in
the US would soon be close to zero that
of course was irresponsible and it was
untrue Trump said it's sort of like the
flu Trump says medical experts should
stop speaking publicly he muzzles people
from talking he's clearly in over his
head but then it really gets bad Trump
bungles testing initially rejecting the
wh OHS test because the CDC was going to
create one CDC fails Trump continues to
brag about how low the number of cases
here is the reason the number is low is
because we aren't testing now
realistically if we were testing right
now we wouldn't have 1,400 cases we
would have anywhere from you know on the
very low end now three thousand eight
nine thousand depending on which
estimate you look at Trump appoints Mike
Pence to run this entire thing a guy who
is almost as clueless as Trump combined
with the weaponization of Mike Pence is
evangelical Christianity which once led
him to pray about what he should do
about an HIV outbreak that was ravaging
his state of Indiana when he was
governor there and then the cherry on
top while Donald Trump is attacking
journalists like cNN's Jim Acosta for
asking him questions about his failed
response while insisting it's not
serious Trump does an emergency
presidential Oval Office national
address during which he incorrectly
states almost every measure being taken
says we have a Europe travel ban except
it really only applies to foreign
nationals coming to the United States
not Americans who want to go back and
forth to their heart's content says the
ban does apply to cargo and trade when
it doesn't and most shockingly most
damaging claims that insurance companies
are waiving all co-payments for virus
treatment when that is not true and
insurance companies in within minutes of
Trump speech immediately come out and
say that's not true we're not waiving
any co-pays on treatment the man can't
handle it he is in over his head he must
resign he never will of course but he
should his narcissism has been
weaponized and combined with his
ignorant history
of grandeur he is building a public
health crisis through his actions
Republicans and the people around him
are enabling him to continue doing it
and lastly Trump may also be sick
himself I know you know that it may not
be the virus but Trump's been in contact
with people exposed to the virus he
could have anything it could be the flu
it could be something else last night
during Trump's address his right eye was
almost swollen shut
his breathing was labored his left eye
which was open was red and shiny and a
Brazilian official that Trump hung out
with over the weekend at mar-a-lago is
now suspected of having the virus
himself that's totally separate from
Trump's incompetence by the way at this
point it's just a side note anyone other
than Trump would be handling this more
competently the owner of the barber shop
down the street from me I would be be
more comfortable with him handling this
than Trump because he wouldn't bring the
chip on his shoulder that Trump brings
that makes him think he knows everything
and not listen to any of the experts the
owner of the travel agency in my
neighborhood who at least understands
how viruses spread through travel right
anyone would be better suited to deal
with this than is Donald Trump today it
is a national nightmare and I don't know
what the eventual outcome is going to be
I I you know for me this is not
political in the sense that if Trump put
together tomorrow a great plan turn this
around and things start going in the
right direction I would gladly say this
is life and death for people I don't
care Republican Democrat Trump whoever
that's all I want the observations I'm
making are not based on Trump's
political party membership or anything
other than this is a fiasco it is hard
to find a country dealing with this more
poorly than Donald Trump is luckily
there are enough health professionals at
lower levels around the country that
they are making some of the right
decisions even without Donald Trump's
involvement help or direction
that's what's saving us at this point in
time national nightmare almost doesn't
even cover it one of our sponsors today
is total AV offering my audience an
entire year of their premium antivirus
software and
they're VPN for just 19 bucks and you
can use both on three of your devices
simultaneously just go to total AV comm
slash David Pakman the link is right
below the video with all of the malware
floating around on the Internet
keeping your computer or other device
unprotected is a risk that I don't
believe is worth taking and total AV
antivirus will keep you safe from
viruses spyware ransomware and adware
works on Windows Mac Android iOS you can
protect your computer phone and tablet
super easy to use you install it once it
runs in the background you don't have to
think about it and meanwhile it's
actively guarding your devices from a
huge range of different threats and as
part of the deal you'll also get total a
V's trusted VPN service which encrypts
all of your Internet traffic hides your
IP address makes you totally anonymous
online websites can't spy on you it's
harder for hackers to steal your
personal info many advantages to using a
VPN you'll get both the antivirus and
the VPN for one whole year on three
devices for just 19 bucks go to total AV
com slash David Pakman link is right
below the video